من غزه ينضم الي لمزيد المتابعه مراسل
الجزيره وائل دحدوح مرحبا وائل اذا التطور
الابرز والاحدث هو هذه البيانات التي جاءت
من الفصائل الفلسطينيه ردا على
الصواريخ التي اطلقتها القوات الاحتلال في
القطاع
هذا صحيح محمد وهذه التصريحات تاتي تباعا
لتؤكد على ذات الموقف الذي تجمع عليه
الفصائل الفلسطينيه هنا في قطاع غزه ازاء
الغارات الاسرائيليه والاعتداءات
الاسرائيليه ايضا في مناطق الضفه الغربيه
والقدس المحتلتين وبالتالي هي تحاول اعاده
التاكيد على المعادلات التي تم تثبيتها
خلال الفتره الماضيه من حاله الاشتباك
والصراع مع جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وموجات التصعيد المتكرره في محاوله لاعاده
انتاج هذه المعادلات وتثبيتها والقول بان
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي غير مسموح
لاختراق هذه المعادلات وتغييرها وتحريفها
عن مسارها وبالتالي هذا كان ايضا فحوى
عمليه اطلاق الصواريخ محمد عندما كانت
الغارات الاسرائيليه تقوم او الطائرات
الاسرائيليه تقوم بشن غارات على قطاع غزه
وان كانت ضد اهداف تتبع لافصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه كانت الصواريخ ايضا اطلقت من
قطاع غزه مره واحده على الاقل باتجاه
اهداف في منطقه الغلاف وهو ايضا اعاده
التاكيد بان قطاع غزه والفصائل الفلسطينيه
في هذا القطاع لن تقف مكتوفه الايدي لا
تجاه السياسه الاسرائيليه سياسه الاستفراد
بمناطق الضفه الغربيه
والاستعراض والاستفزاز وقتل المواطنين
الفلسطينيين في مناطق مختلفه من الضفه
الغربيه ولا حتى ازاء سياسه الاحتلال
باللجوء الى شنغارات وان كانت ضد اهداف
عسكريه تتبع لفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
ولذلك كان اطلاق الصواريخ يحمل هذا المغزى
اضافه الى اطلاق المضادات الارضيه التي
بيتنا نراها بشكل
يعني متتالي في كل الغارات التي تشن من
قبل الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وحسب
المعلومات فان هناك اطلاق لي المضادات
الارضيه تجاه الطائرات التي شاركت في هذه
الغارات بشكل عام الاوضاع في قطاع غزه على
حالها منذ ان انتهت الطائرات الاسرائيليه
من شن هاتين الغارتين اللتين استهدفتا
موقعين يتبعان لكتائب القسام الجناح
العسكري لحركه حماس في منطقه شمال غرب
مدينه غزه والمنطقه الوسطى من القطاع
اقتصرت النتائج على الاضرار التي لحقت
بهذين الموقعين لكن دون وقوع اصابات في
صفوف المواطنين او حتى في صفوف المقاومين
الفلسطينيين هناك معلومات عن اضرار طفيفه
وقعت في بعض نوافذ الزجاج في بعض المنازل
الق نسبيا من هذه المواقع اللاسيمه في
المنطقه منطقه مدينه غزه
وبالتالي حتى اصوات الطائرات تراجعت الى
حد كبير
وربما على غير العاده حتى اصوات طائرات
الاستطلاع المسيره لم نعد نستمع اليها
بتلك الكثافه التي عاده ما تكون سائده في
اجواء قطاع غزه وكما يبدو كل هذا الى جانب
البيان الذي صدر من جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ربما
رسائل من جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ينقلها
عبر الميدان بطريقه غير مباشره الى
الفصائل الفلسطينيه بان جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لا يريد تفجير الاوضاع مع قطاع
غزه ولكن قطاع غزه يقول بانه لن يقف مكتوف
الايدي تجاهه ما يجري من حاله استفراد في
الضفه الغربيه وهو الامر الذي اكدت عليه
كل البيانات والتصريحات الصحفيه التي صدرت
عن المستويات السياسيه او عن المستويات
العسكريه في في قطاع غزه وتتبع لي فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه هناك اليوم حاله من
الحداد والاضراب المدارس بكافه مراحلها
سواء المدارس الحكوميه او الخاصه اغلقت
ابوابها في حاله اضراب احتجاجا على ما جرى
في مدينه نابلس بالضفه الغربيه وايضا كانت
هناك مسيرات انطلقت واعتصامات في اكثر من
مكان ومنطقه في قطاع غزه للتنديد بهذه
المجزره كما اسواها وبالتالي المزاج
الفلسطيني مزاج يعني محتقن جدا وغاضب جدا
تجاه هذه السياسه الاسرائيليه شكرا جزيلا
الدحدوح اذا
فيما هو واضح الطرفان يحافظان على قواعد
الاشتباك التي هي مثبته فعليا منذ اشهر
شكرا جزيلا بتاكيل ساعود اليك في حال ورود
اي تطور جديد شكرا جزيلا مره اخرى
والدحدوح من قطاع غزه